[Music]
happy new year everyone hey I'm Matt
fire roar I'm the game director on the
Elder Scrolls online at ZeniMax online
studios it's another year another time
for another big announcement on Elder
Scrolls online but first twenty nineteen
was a great year for us we were mmog of
the year again we went to elsewhere it
was the first time we told a year long
story over the entire for updates of the
year it was really successful we had
lots of fun but late last year you know
we dropped some hints about where we're
going next we're really excited about
what's coming next we're really excited
about what we're going to show you today
so thank you all of you in the ESO
community worldwide ESO would not exist
in its current form without the life
that you bring to the game so thanks we
are concentrating even more on the
year-long story in a place that's very
familiar to every Elder Scrolls player
we'll be talking about the year-long
theme the chapter and how it all ties
together we're really excited about this
so welcome everyone to the dark heart of
sky
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage Pete Hines and rich Lambert
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's just Las Vegas talking that's
what that is Wow yes I am Uncle Pete
also known as Pete Hines from Bethesda
and with me in pants so you know it's a
big day
creative director at ZeniMax online
studios rich Lambert rich how are you
good
[Applause]
this is amazing you know the energy in
this room is so high I get to be up here
with you we haven't done this since
morrowind since more one yep and we
haven't actually ever done this in front
of a live studio audience before and
it's amazing to have so many people from
the ESO community here together and
thank you guys for coming in and joining
us and of course thanks everybody
watching us online around the world
we're streaming on Twitch and Facebook
YouTube mixer you name it we're
streaming on it and for those of you
watching us on stream we've got some
stretch goals today as you may know last
year those stretch goals ended up with
rich getting a tattoo on his leg despite
despite his fear of needles yeah what
are our goals this year if we hit 80
thousand concurrent viewers and that's
across all of our different platforms
combined everybody is going to get a
long winged bet bat pet say that five
times fast
and if we really knock it out of the
park and reach a hundred and fifty
thousand concurrent viewers rich and I
are going to be doing the snow Bear
Plunge you know I got attached to it
because of the community my hair still
purple because the community we're
getting we're probably gonna get wet
look I've been practicing my fingers at
a time and a glass of cold water like
I've already I've already started
trading for this it's happening so we
rich we just took a look at the trailer
from the trailer and the name wild guess
we're headed to Skyrim we are we're
going Skyrim it is a little different
than the Skyrim that you knew and kind
of grew up with in test five but it's
going to feel familiar yeah your long
adventure kind of gothic and I mean a
little dark you got to see in the
trailer there it's dark it's it's gothic
it is this very interesting adventure
that takes you all throughout familiar
places and unfamiliar place so it's
gonna feel familiar to skyrim fans I
assume we have some of those here I mean
we've already released it like 47 times
on 57
we haven't played yet I don't know what
to tell you we put it out as many times
as possible but at the same time it's
gonna feel very different in Antonio
feel not only de Skyrim but even to the
ESO we know Skyrim as we know it in eso
because there is some of Skyrim India so
there is we you know at launch
we had the eastern portion of Skyrim so
the Rift East March like Rock Island and
so we decided to focus more on the
western side and you know exploring what
that was and some of the iconic places
there and and dark heart dark heart of
Skyrim meaning well we're gonna actually
take you to the dark heart of sky mm-hmm
interesting and this is once again this
is gonna be a whole year story so this
is not just sort of hey come check out
this DLC when we lease it here and
that's kind of the beginning and end of
it this is all year long yeah like last
year with season of the Dragon we're
telling this year long connected story
that all for updates are very heavily
tied together to tell this narrative
that was something that we got a lot of
feedback on last year with elsewhere
they liked that they wanted the story to
be even more integrated and so we did
that each of the the DLCs that we do are
all very tied directly to the story and
we do still have that big elsewhere like
chapter this time around we do so we're
kicking off the year with quarter one in
the dungeon DLC called Harrow storm and
the story of dark heart kicks off there
there's a prologue quest and whatnot and
then it really kicks into gear in
quarter two with the grimoire chapter
and great more chapter is going to be
going up for people purchased like right
now so all of you want to jump on it and
pre-purchase and we'll be talking a
little later in the stream about some of
the goodies you get if you want to go
ahead and pre-purchase gray more but
that'll be a bill starting today so
we're getting a new experience in a
familiar location we're expanding the
area of skyrim a little bit but like
what's new in in what I'm going to be
able to go and do where I'm gonna be
able to explore you mentioned okay well
you've been in the eastern part we're
gonna head west what does that mean
we're going west it's the site of Kings
Bagram
he hasn't joined the oven heart pact so
it's a very different story it's a
little bit more political it is also
this very almost supernatural dark
storyline where there are weird
storms ravaging the countryside there's
werewolves and vampires and witches and
it's kind of up to you to figure out
what's going on and how they all are if
they all interconnect however the
locations gonna feel different biome
wise like we we get one singular thing
you break it up into a couple how I
split it we're splitting it up like we
do in all the other chapters there's
generally three biomes
when we do that the northern portion of
the zone is what you would expect ice
and snow that's incidentally where
solitude is that maybe iconic city I
know how I know you're very still than
you get to go have fun exploring that
and seeing it in a different light
though we're a thousand years or almost
a thousand years before the events of
testimony so it's going to be a little
bit different and then as you kind of
progress through the zone you move more
towards the lowlands so rolling hills a
little bit of you know that Tundra
arctic boggy feel and I know you know
there's some interesting locations there
that your play I mean certainly both
when it was in development and then
afterwards just for fun I spent a ton of
time in Skyrim both for work as well as
just for having a good time and
unwinding from work so yeah very
familiar with solitude and some of the
other places that we're gonna be talking
about you mentioned the like we're gonna
be visiting these places it's a thousand
years in the past but you guys are not
doing the same kind of one-to-one that
you did for say the more wind chapter
where it was much more about hey you
know this part of the world from this
game and we're gonna kind of recreate it
you're taking a different approach here
in dark heart chuckle oh yeah we want it
to feel familiar but we also want to go
off and forge our own kind of thing and
so we're telling different stories we're
taking you to those familiar locations
you know solitude in WA not but also
going on other places and really diving
deep into the dark heart of sky so this
is going to take place both above ground
although you and I both know the first
question fans love to ask when you talk
about you know going to a new place is
okay how big is it is as big as this as
big as you know down to the square inch
they want to know size-wise
but this especially this community they
but this is a little this is a little
different in terms of like if you just
look at it on the map it's actually not
gonna appear as big as some of the other
ones but that's a little misleading
you're right so it's not one whole
contiguous space you know there is the
Overland space which is Western Skyrim
and then there is this huge underground
cavern down below Skyrim called black
reach and we're gonna spans you're gonna
get to spend a lot of time down there
yeah by the way this is not like hey
it's really big and it's like this one
thing over here we're talking like yeah
a percent forty percent of the playable
landmass for the chapter is down in
black reach you're gonna go to never
before discovered locations in black
reach so I mean duh vampires werewolves
they don't like being out so they
they've got a whole underground they do
you're gonna get to find out more about
what that is and who's down there and
why they're down and but it's not just
underground we're going to some places
that we are familiar with above-ground
we mentioned solitude north all north
all is there and it's that same kind of
feel you know that creepy foggy boggy
kind of area there's a twist in it in
our timeline we won't spoil it but it's
gonna feel similar but different
interestingly you know the thing I
remember about more thaw in Skyrim is
that's the first place I came across
vampires while playing the game because
you go there's the house burned down and
the poor little girl and you've got to
figure out what happened to the house
and there's a vampire lord who's trying
to trying to take over north also cool
that that's in there and that's gonna be
part of some story that you don't want
to tell us I don't know I don't spoil it
too much is it safe to say it's vampire
like like ish yes and black reach now
black reach is an amazing area in the
elderscrolls v skyrim it's also really
friggin hard to get to like I don't know
if any of you have ever tried to get to
reach you have to swim all the way to
basically where you think the game is
gonna you know cut off the map through
ice floes and there's some random hermit
in a cave who's like oh I have the magic
flues it to let you get into the black
we're talking about like doing this and
I'm like okay well what are the some
locations and black reach did you ever
go there and I was like no what where
the hell do I get the black reach and
I'm wandering around like oh I have to
have some stupid artifact to get into
here and so like once I got it and I got
to go in there like oh my god it's it's
amazing it's this huge cavernous but
that's also the beauty of what that team
does right where you can play the game
for hundreds of hours and still not
discover everything that's massive it's
just round it's really amazing and so we
tried to do a lot of the same things in
in ESO and so how do you take something
like black reach that exists in Skyrim
in some form but what you're doing with
it obviously is a much bigger scale it's
not just gonna be to the size like
you're you're going even we're going
bigger you know they're the places that
you know from test five are there but
we're going deeper and exploring there's
actually multiple different types of
biomes in black earth within black
regions within black reach so while
you're wandering around you're gonna
learn more about the creatures there and
see some very interesting things there's
two women ruins down there there's
vampires down there like you said as
well so lots of cool stuff dragon bridge
Dragon Bridge is in there so you can
just see that and explore that and
there's some sort of on the dungeon side
underground places I remember like
shadow green which is a really
interesting unique cavern in scar very
different thematically labyrinthian any
chance we see we have both those so
shadow green is a Delft where you get to
go and explore that it's a little bit
different we're a thousand years in the
past so some of the trees probably
aren't as big as they would be and then
labyrinthian is a very large public
dungeon so you get to go around and
explore that and just see what all that
is in there but again all of this is
kind of you guys taking some some
locations that we know but making it
your own in terms of how big they are
what's going on there you're not really
tide given the different
and time yeah we get to do it on
investing like sell our own stories
which is fun there's a lot of new ground
to cover in Tamriel when you've got that
but there's more than geography talk to
us about this story like what what is
the story that you're telling across the
year of dark heart of Skyrim what is it
about what a player's gonna experience
it is a very dark story it is I guess
the closest thing you could relate it to
is Reve inspire for those that you know
play that you know that that feel that
really dark feel if centers around
vampires and werewolves and which is and
people disappearing and it's very
different than what elsewhere was you
know elsewhere was you know dragons
which were really cool big bulky
creatures but it was in the land of the
Khajiit and the Khajiit are you know
these little bit off the wall very
happy-go-lucky people and that's not
what the Nords are at all and you said
this is similar to how we've done in the
past like what we did with seasons of a
dragon so so functionally which is it
breaking up into the same number of DLCs
the same types of DLCs what can players
yeah so it's it's the kind of typical
for major updates over the course of the
year there's two dungeon DLCs there's
the chapter and then there's also the
story DLC that culminates the entire
year okay and two of those you mentioned
so Harris storm and gray more and gray
more and then two more coming we have
two more coming that we will talk about
at a later date maybe e3 yeah alright
now one of the things you guys do a lot
in when you do these chapters when you
do these DLCs is you'll bring npcs back
that are that are player favorites
either from you know previous story
lines and Elder Scrolls online and and
you you and I both laughed and we were
over there waiting to come up because we
got a big reaction with lyrics yeah is
art she's bad how our second born is
back for sure she is
[Applause]
she is your guide and mentor throughout
the entire year Jennifer Hale Jennifer
Hale is back as the voice of lyricist so
that's really exciting and then yeah one
of the things that the team really
enjoys is trying to bring back
characters that people show the rest of
who else could we expect Desai slurs
everybody's favorite hated dark elf and
nurses dren is back we are going to
Skyrim
so of course rigor the brash is gonna be
back course you're gonna get the seed
you know and learn more about who he is
and what he's all about and then we are
also gonna have some members of the
Raven watch which are excellent so we've
got some places that we know from from
previous Elder Scrolls games some
characters that that were familiar with
and this really interesting story it's a
lot of mystery going on but one thing we
know for sure is that there's no mystery
about how excited your team is in doing
this and the things that they're doing
at dark hardest guy we spoke to some of
the devs and asked the ask them to share
their thoughts on making dark art of
Skyrim and put together a little video
let's take a look my favorite part of
playing through Skyrim has always been
that layered storytelling that turn a
corner and something new is gonna happen
and some new adventure is gonna kick off
right and that influenced us us in the
way that we build the Elder Scrolls
online and it certainly influenced us in
the way that we've been building dark
art Schuyler
as a storyteller it's always exciting to
take existing locations existing lore
expanding upon that and then merging it
with new places that we're creating
we've seen East March before we've seen
the rift that we're going to see what's
going on on the western half of the
continent it's ruled by a guy named King
spar Grimm who is not at all happy about
the fact that he's got Joran making
friends with Dark Elves and argonians
Kings far Grimm didn't join the oven
heart pact he's operating on his own and
he's not kind of happy with the rest of
Skyrim reach men are a threat but
there's more threatening the people of
western Skyrim now it's a much more
darker more gothic story every lord
knows the legend of black reach they
grow up hearing stories around the
campfire nobody believes it's true
it's one of the best moments from Skyrim
you descend down into the ground and
you've emerged into this absolutely
insane dwarven city that you had no idea
was under your feet the whole time we
are taking that idea and we're kind of
expanding upon it like it's not only
under that one part of Skyrim maybe this
cave extends throughout the entirety of
Skyrim and it's always underneath your
feet wherever you go you know the Dwemer
have been down here and what else has
been down here of what other adventurers
are down here so deep underground out of
the sunlight of course you're going to
encounter vampires
vampires and elder scrolls they are all
evil which is kind of scary - where did
this strain of vampirism come from what
makes these vampires scarier than other
vampires we've encountered before we
really wanted this part of Skyrim to
really be familiar to people if you're
in more Thal you know that if you go
south you're gonna get to labyrinthian
we want people to step into solitude we
want people to remember those streets I
was gonna flip a table if we didn't get
to go to the wiki Skeever now we didn't
get the call at the weekend Skeever
but we still get to go there and that
was that was far enough for me it feels
like going home to a certain extent
coming home and finding there's a new
room waiting for you in the back of the
house that's full of mystery surprises
and a lot of deep
you know you know it's a hardcore Elder
Scrolls group when they get jazzed over
a winking ski like the biggest response
to the videos for the winking ski BRR
okay so we've talked about we're gonna
do this story over the course of the
entire year over these DLCs and I want
to actually skip ahead and not skip over
here a storm let's talk about grain war
and first of all what what is great more
what
so grain war is the name of the key
that's deep in the center of black reach
this is one of the seats of power for
the vampire Lord that resides there and
the story you know touches a little bit
on him but the chapter overall is
follows the same kind of pattern that
they all do in that there is roughly 30
hours of new content
there's main story there's side content
in there you get to learn a lot more
about the people that are living in the
area and then there's also all the other
trappings that usually come along with
that in to public dungeons there's a
number of delves there's a new dark
anchor like form of gameplay in the zone
called Harrow storms and then of course
there's a new 12 player trial called
coins ages they do they're making like
very happy is available for pre-purchase
now there's two other things that are
coming in this that are like interesting
conditions above and beyond everything
that you just rat it off and the first
one is called antiquities it's a whole
new system and we put together a video
talking a little bit about what it is so
let's take a look at that first
antiquities are really super exciting
particularly for a lower buff like me
it's not combat it's not questing it's
the first time we've added anything like
this since how's it so it's a whole new
verb to add to your adventure and
repertoire so antiquities is divided
into two different kind of exciting
activities the first is scrying player
will get an item
antiquarians I which is this really cool
alien scrying device you'll have to use
the antiquarians eye to discover where
this antiquity might be hidden and when
you find where that antiquity is hidden
then you'll have to excavate it once
you've obtained the antiquity then
you've acquired this treasure from a
bygone era you'll get to find things
from eras that none of the Elder Scrolls
games have touched yet that should give
players really cool insight into the
history of Tamriel which is something
that we're all really super passionate
about so I think this will fill a void
for characters and players who want to
explore more of Tamriel history like
we're already in the second era which is
before any other Elder Scrolls game but
with antiquities we can reach even
further back into the past and start
getting scholarly insights and fragments
of history from times even before that
another cool thing about the antiquity
system is is that if you're looking for
an opportunity to do something that
doesn't involve you like storming a cave
and kicking an ogre in the face this is
a cool way to do that it you can go and
travel the world and find cool stuff
they're going to be in base game zones
they're gonna be in chapter zones DLC
zones and zones that we released going
forward they're going to be everywhere
it's mostly about you and the open road
and antiquities you can find
[Music]
okay so in sick of these are a big deal
and as we said at the end of that video
not just specific to this part that
we're adding to its it's gonna
incorporate the entire games game line a
past president and a future in fiction
how does it work what how does that
Integrity's work so I guess the best way
to summarize kind of the feel of the
system would be Indiana Jones in Tamriel
so you are this person that is scouring
the countryside
you know looking for interesting bits of
lore interesting relics you know as the
guy said on the video this is not your
typical questing and killing it's a
completely different form of gameplay
where there's these two new minigames
two new skill lines that are associated
with those minigames that help you get
better at antiquity antiquities you know
the first minigame scrying is heavily
influenced by a color or shape match
game and that's what you do to zero in
on the location of these these objects
and then you have to physically go to
that location in the world and do the
excavation minigame the digging minigame
and that is heavily influenced by like a
minesweeper or battleship and once you
dig up the item you get this cool thing
and the the really fun part about this
system is we try to appeal to all types
of players you know there's kind of
something in there for everybody you
know when you dig up the object
obviously you want a trophy for your
house so there's tons of new furnishings
you can put them in your in your house
[Applause]
there are all kinds of new cool
cosmetics for your character you know
there's all types of stuff in there
there's emotes there's a brand new mount
and the really astute person watching
that video might have seen it in that
video there I think we might show it a
little bit later and then there's a
brand new type of gear that you can get
called mythic items there's even PvP
stuff there is there's actually a siege
weapon that you can get nice I mean
first of all I mean you had a solid
Indiana so cool done mythic items what
are they how they work the
our new unique items they only come at
CP 160 Gold level gear so they're high
quality items they're different in that
you can only wear one of them at a time
and they have unique properties to them
so a couple of examples there is a piece
of jewelry that you can get that when
you equip it it increases your movement
speed in combat when you're outside of a
combat it actually doubles that movement
speed so it's this new interesting way
to kind of play the game and equip your
character there's also a heavy chest
that you can put on that when you block
it actually restores Magica so and but
you'd only have one of these can only
equip one of them at a time and again
the whole idea is for Antiquities is
regardless of your play style a it's not
a like go kill a bunch of stuff or it's
not a quest thing this is at your own
pace when you want and there's gonna be
stuff for every type of every type of
player and the beauty is is really you
know this is a system that you can do at
your own pace and so those players that
might not necessarily have access to
guilds or you know a ton of friends that
can go into the trials and do that the
high-end stuff they get some really cool
new gear and new gizmos they can do it
that yeah
so we said two things one of which is
and two Cooney's the other is your
revamping the vampire skill line dark
heart is your vamping vampires
yeah I mean this year is you know
heavily influenced by it by vampires and
so we thought it would be a really good
opportunity to go back and look at the
skill line and look at the experience
and the team looked at everything from
the abilities to the passives there's a
brand new ultimate ability that I won't
spoil with it and it's this whole new
package so it's this fully realized
skill line and experience so you can
like necromancy if you do overt vampire
actions in the world the justice system
will report you cards you'll give
bounties and then the team even looked
at just the feeding mechanism in it of
itself and we becomes like a page from
the dark brotherhood and blade of woe
we're now feeding has these really cool
new paired animations where you feel
like you're actually feeding I actually
saw a prototype animation just before
this where you know you kind of sneak up
behind somebody and you jump on their
back and gnaw on their neck and there's
viscera and gore and cut all this like
it is a vampire experience which is
really cool I am curious when you're
working with something like a vampire
skill line is is sucking like a stated
goal
the vampire stream all right yeah the
last one I don't know that again yes all
right so now you know me I have a pet
peeve about this which is I can't stand
when a game company or publisher says
there's never been a better time to play
game X everybody always says that but
there's a lot of people who maybe either
haven't played Elder Scrolls online for
a while or have never played it and so
the question is without saying that how
do you explain to somebody all right I'm
thinking about getting into this game
but you've got dark heart of Skyrim and
gray more we've got more win we've got
all of this content like how do I know
where I'm supposed to jump into this and
and start so that's the beauty of Elder
Scrolls online is it's really up to you
you know we don't have arbitrary level
gates that prevent you from playing with
your friends are going and exploring you
can from level 1 go to the brand new
content and play it and experience it
and have a good time you can play ESO
any way you want you know if you want to
be a mage in heavy armor and a shield
you can do that if you want to throw
fireballs you know you can do that as
well it's it's it's up to you and we
don't dictate to you how to play if you
want to play Elder Scrolls online as a
single player you can do that and then
when you're ready you can play with your
friends so dark dark heart of Skyrim is
something that I mean like these folks
play a ton of the game maxed out there's
still lots of colors than for Yun's of
things but if you're new and want to
jump in and have this be the first thing
it's not like well you got to go do this
other stuff you can start off in grey
Mord date up and do from level 1 and
just start playing cool now I know that
these folks in particular and some of
our more hardcore players were not super
happy with us about something with
elsewhere which is we decided not to do
a collector's edition for elsewhere and
they were like dude what the hell
where's our collector's edition we love
the collector's edition so we heard you
and we're doing one this time around
[Applause]
so we are doing a physical collector's
edition it comes with a really sweet
statue some collectors coins a map every
Elder Scrolls game has to ship with a
man I think it's a law until a ton of
digital goodies a whole bunch of stuff
including in a mote pack that I mean
because we haven't driven arrow to the
knee completely into the ground yet we
had to have an arrow to the knee a mode
and it comes with a free month of Elder
Scrolls online plus which you can either
use for yourself or if you've got a
friend if you're already an ESO Plus
subscriber you can gift it to anybody
that you want so yeah and that's always
I mentioned before pre-purchase
available for graeme or there's all
kinds of digital goodies available if
you want to pre-purchase great more it
includes an all-new mount the hole
breaker warhorse and if you pre-purchase
grave or you can start using the mount
immediately so you don't have to wait
until grade mower comes out you'll get
the mount right away and can start
riding around go to the website for all
the details and info on everything in
the seee
and in the pre-purchase goodies so okay
I said I wanted to start with gray more
but now we're gonna go back to the first
one that's coming out so the first one
is new DLC it comes out this quarter
Harrow storm it's gonna be on pts index
Winx next week it'll be up with you so
what can you tell us about girls so
Harris storm is you know a - dungeon DLC
it contains the prologue which really
kicks the story off for for the entire
year and the the dungeons themselves one
is called ice reach it takes you to the
sea of ghosts and you learn more about
these really weird storms you know I
touched on those a little bit in the ice
reach coven and the other dungeon is
called unhallowed grave and that is an
ancient burial site that was under
protection for some reason was heavily
guarded and has since kind of been
forgotten about and there's a group or
somebody in there digging up whatever
was entombed in there
okay and you said before that you're
really trying to do more of the story
earlier on and not just waiting for okay
here's this big chapter in quarter two
so Harris storms gonna include much more
story in terms of what's going on what
you find out in the dungeon lays a very
strong foundation for the entire year
now the Hera Storm update is not just
about that deal so you're also doing a
bunch of updates to the game itself as
part of that release later later this
quarter what is that gonna include so
back in July I think it was we posted a
performance road map update upon Elder
Scrolls online comm and we've been
updating it over the course every month
we've been updating here's the progress
here's where we're going with this you
saw a little bit of that at the end of
the year with some of the memory memory
improvements that we did but this year
the very first really big one is the
patching overall and that's gonna cause
everybody or require everybody to
redownload the entire game but once you
do the game's gonna be significantly
smaller on disk almost 30 gigabytes
smaller which is massive and and it's
gonna result in the game running faster
loading faster frame weights gonna be a
little bit better and hatches going
forward are gonna be smaller shorter
down times smaller patches improve
stability all of all stuff is coming
starting with and this isn't the only
one but this is the start this is the
start of the entire year like that's the
other big part of this year long story
is the performance aspect of it alright
so Harris storm coming out q1 we put
together video to talk a little bit more
about about what you can expect take a
look this your adventure into the dark
heart of Skyrim starts with Harris storm
which focuses on two dungeons Ice reach
and unhallowed grave
discovering the mysteries in these two
dungeons are a gateway to the larger
dark heart of sky our ice reaches this
island in the middle to see it ghost and
there's this mysterious storm swirling
about so an expedition was sent there to
figure out what's going on and they
haven't returned once the player arrives
on the island in search of the missing
expeditionary force they come across
Lear's titan born and they team up with
her in order to discover what the
witches are doing on the island and put
a stop to this mysterious storm as you
travel across the island you're gonna
come across multiple witches each with
their own type of magic some leggings
fire some are gonna use electricity
and they also have other minions and
creatures that they're going to bring to
fights
on how a grave is this mass burial of
bones that has been underground and
sealed away for thousands of years by
the pyre watch and it's been so long
that what exactly was down here is
actually unknown to them and they
appointed people to watch over it
they had one job to do and they couldn't
do that right because somebody broke in
not only is the player going to have to
deal with the Nordic mercenaries but the
defenders that the ancient higher watch
left here to guard the tomb and you were
discovering what was left down here and
what the Nordic mercenaries are looking
for
[Applause]
what about you want to know what is that
you're gonna tell us what that is
you'll find out next week so we've got
Harrow storm coming mid-march but it's
gonna be on pts next week we've got
great more coming out in q2 anything
else you want to tell us about what's
coming 20 20 maybe second half of the
year yeah I mean we've only touched on
quarter one in quarter two we're gonna
talk more about quarter three and
quarter four at e3 but one is gonna be a
dungeon DLC and the other one is going
to be that story DLC okay but we got I
mean we've got all these people here
like like whatever what if we just
promised just in this room what if you
just tell us just in this or just us
like a little teams like like something
all right I like that that's good so as
long as it just stays in this just in
this room just to misremember towns in
Vegas stays in Vegas
I like that okay okay how about this if
you are at all interested or familiar
with lore about the reach you might be
really excited about the coming fourth
quarter okay so so maybe you're so
you're telling me there's a chance we're
going there's a chance okay well find
out more at e3 okay but for now we got
Harris storm we're looking forward to
gray more any last words any last
thoughts you want to share with folks
yeah I mean I think this year is poised
to be remarkable for ESO you know we've
got all this really cool new content
these new systems coming in the
community is continuing to grow and
expand we have actually seen you know
our Russia community grow significantly
over over the past year or two so we're
actually going to localize ESO in
Russian so text-only there's a lot of
friggin text those small faces but yeah
there's there's gonna be a fully
supported official localized Russian SKU
that's awesome and I mean entirely
the community in Russia he's supposed to
support the game have been so awesome
and one other thing I wanted to ask you
stadia we were part of the stadia stuff
and we got a few questions like hey what
what's up with that we get that a lot
yeah and we haven't forgotten about it
we're still hard at work on that and
we'll probably talk a little bit more
about that at e3 awesome okay I think
that's about it rich thank you so much
thank you deeds is a blast thank you
everybody for coming out thank you guys
so much for joining us in person or
everybody who joined us on the stream we
are gonna go right to the post show but
before we do let's take one more look at
the trailer for darker sky
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so welcome to the